unicode characters are just plain
awesome as you just learned there are
more than 110,000 characters that is
insane in a moment i want you to explore
some of them because well they can
certainly come in handy why would you
ever force the browser to download an
image when there's already a unicode
character that you can get for free to
explore them in yourself i recommend
checking out this dropdown menu which
gives you the chance to look through all
of the different categories you can find
things like emoticons holy cow look at
all those cute little emoticons that you
get for free which you can use on any
website it's worth pointing out that in
order to use unicode characters you need
to make sure that you set your character
set to utf-8 inside your meta tag see
the instructor notes for more details on
this for this quiz I want you to pretend
that you are making a music website
check out the link to the unicode
character set that you can find in the
instructor notes look through it and see
if you can find the symbol for the
treble clef once you found it try it out
for yourself and see if it works
once you're done paste the HTML code
here to continue